c'était le cop terre asperges une
plantation avec du glyphosate herbicide
puis ça l'objectif est d'éliminer tous
les arbres qui font de la compétition
aux conifères au boisé quelques années
plus tard les trembler les feuillus ne
sont plus que des chicots sans vie les
conifères eux résistent et prospère
l'activiste james snyder milite contre
l'utilisation du glyphosate en forêt
story en 2017 au canada plus de 80 mille
hectares de coupes forestières ont été
traités de la sorte dont plus de dix
mille en colombie-britannique pour
quelqu'un qui ne va pas en forêt ça
semble parfaitement normal c'est
verdoyant les arbres poussent rapidement
mais en même temps c'est une seule
espèce d'arbre sont incroyablement
inflammables
[Musique]
à l'été 2010 est la communauté de
williams lake au sud de prince george a
dû être évacué
deux ans plus tard la chercheuse laurie
daniel étudie le comportement de ce feu
historique
elle s'intéresse au rôle qu'ont joué les
feuillus comme ici près de l'aéroport
le feu se diriger dans cette direction
quand il a atteint une section avec
quelques feuilles où il a perdu de son
intensité
et quand il est arrivé à s'étrangle il a
été freiné les arbres ont tous survécu
laurie daniel estime que l'utilisation
du glyphosate est dépassé les feuillus
selon elle devraient être perçues comme
des alliés et non pas comme une nuisance
aux conifères qui sont recherchés par
l'industrie il est temps de repenser et
transformer notre gestion de la forêt il
faut penser à augmenter la diversité
pour accroître la résilience
il faut que notre territoire soit géré
pour être mieux préparée face aux
incendies et aux ravageurs avec les
changements climatiques
ce sont ces perturbations qui vont
déterminer l'avenir de notre forêt
[Musique]
le ministère des forêts de la colombie
britannique a refusé notre demande
d'entrevue
un porte parole a rappelé que
l'utilisation du glyphosate était
réglementé et sécuritaire ici maxime
corneau radio canada prince george